No, no, no, no, no.
Load Ninja Trader. Load Ninja Trader.
Come on. Open, open, open.
Okay, where are the levels? Where are
the levels? There's a huge level right
here. 10,000 shares. 150 a share.
That's too expensive. Just kidding.
Trading in the market is not like that.
And if you are doing it like that,
you're doing it wrong.
Cuz this is where kind of the glory of a
fluid stop loss come into play.
Yep, we're out. Sick trade.
And so I basically wake up 45 minutes
before the market opens at 9:30. The
first thing I do every morning is I open
up a website called Forex Factory. And
what this does is it tells me the
important news that is happening that
day. It's extremely important to know
what's going on during your trading
time. I only trade 60 minutes about in
the morning because I've realized that
is the time window for me to be as
effective as possible. And so generally
what I'll do if there's news at 9:45
a.m. or 10:00 a.m., I'll mark that on my
chart. Now, my morning routine before
that isn't anything special. It's all
about doing what works for you. I don't
have some crazy 5:00 a.m. wake up
routine. All you need to do is do what
makes sense for you to get you ready to
trade. I show up about 15 minutes before
the market actually opens at 9:15
Eastern Standard Time. And what I do is
I open up a 15-minute chart of the S&P
500 futures and the Nasdaq futures. And
so what I'm looking for here is I only
trade reversals. I've realized over time
that doing that for me has been very
effective. It simplifies things. It
gives me a really good risk reward
because essentially I'm looking to sell
tops and buy bottoms in the market. And
so I can risk a small amount to make a
large amount. Now these trades don't
show up very often, but when they do,
they can be very, very powerful. And so
what I do first thing on that 15-minute
chart is I look for key areas where I
think the market is going to reverse.
And so this morning, looking at a
15-minute chart, is right here we have
actually a upwards resistance trend
line. And also I would draw a resistance
zone up here that the market is
currently moving up into. And just to
keep track of the lows as well, there's
kind of a support zone here. And so what
I'm going to look for this morning is
does the market come up here and fail
and look to reverse lower, and then I'll
take a trade to the downside risking a
small amount to make a large amount.
Also I like to zoom kind of out and look
at the big picture. Big picture, the
market has been very volatile over the
last couple days. And so currently it's
kind of in this big bull flag, which is
a continuation trend to the upside. But
if this fails, we are in this sideways
range right here over the last couple
days. So I think it's likely that we
could reverse. And just the fact of the
big picture of the market is very back
and forth. This big move up here has a
good chance to reverse lower as well. I
don't necessarily think I'll capture
this whole move that's huge cuz I'm day
trading on a 1-minute chart, but a move
like this would be a great trade. And
then after that, I go into a 1-minute
chart and you can see my zone show up
here and also that upwards trend line.
And so I like to mark down here 9:45
and 10:00 a.m. for those news times, but
also what I've realized over time is
these are key timings in the morning
where the market is likely to start a
reversal if it does. And so, if the
market comes up here and spikes and
reverses at this timing, I would look to
jump in at this area to get a trade. So,
to just show you a quick example of what
I'm looking for every day I trade, the
market opens up for me 7:30. I like to
look for a spike lower. It's at a
reversal zone. Here, it's actually done
a breakout, but I'm looking for a failed
breakout to happen. And this downtrend
it has is broken, and then I'm looking
for a head and shoulders pattern here.
And then I jump in long right here and
bet that the market's going to go higher
and capture the reversal the other
direction. And so, just swapping to the
recording of that with me is you can see
here, entered in down here after that
head and shoulders, and then capture a
move up. And I risk about $1,500 to
$1,700 per trade right now. I like to
target 3x. I tend to get about that
much, but I fluidly manage things as the
market plays out. So, that's what I kind
of look for every single day. This trade
closed out for a $4,800, $4,600. And
then I'm done with the day about 45
minutes in or 10:00 a.m. market standard
time. And so, as we get into today,
these don't show up every single day. I
get a few trades a week because I'm very
patient and picky about things. Not
every day I get a win. Sometimes I go
break even. Sometimes I could take a
loss. But over the long run with the
strategy and how the risk reward ratio
is set up, my winners make more money
than my losers, and so I make money over
time. And so, the market's starting to
open here, and so we're going to get
into patiently waiting for a setup to
happen. Okay, so this morning is really
interesting.
Uh these levels on the ES and Nasdaq
pretty much the same. We have a nice
like overnight we we're just in this
range kind of right now the last few
days. We have this kind of uptrend that
looks like we're pretty much
pushing to right now.
Um we had a pre-market spike here from
news, and then we pushed up. And so,
what I'm really seeing is it looks like,
you know, we might sell off and give
this back up.
So, it's made a new low here. I
essentially want to see it pull back
some,
test, and then I'll put my short or my
um entry below this. So, essentially
I'll do it here.
And I think having my stop somewhere up
here, I think it's fine. I want to see
this candlestick pull back here.
Even just up to here. I want to see an
attempt to break up higher, fail,
and then I'll get in short.
I can even put my stop all the way up
here.
Looks like it's going to fill me.
That it still looks good to go lower.
It's just not great, but again, the big
picture is great.
Order
>> and I'm going to move my stop to here.
Kind of sucks that it one ticked me, and
then it's pulling back, but
either way, anything can happen. Even on
the the 15-minute chart here,
I think this looks great as
testing this trend line, testing this
resistance,
um and, you know, doing this kind of
move.
Now, managing this,
I mean, I think I'm just going to I'm
trying to just kind of let it play out.
You know, it was slow.
This is a nice break, but I'm assuming
because it's been sluggish here,
it's most likely going to stay doing
that. So, I want to let it do its thing,
you know, because the big picture, I
think, this is a great spike lower. You
know, once it's we come down to this
area, that's more of the support area.
And so, in the middle here, it's kind of
like just seeing
how it plays out.
This could totally spike up here and
knock me out basically at break even,
but um you know, that's how it goes,
right?
This is where kind of the glory of a
fluid stop loss can come into play
is when it just starts to go crazy like
this. Um and I'm just going to, you
know, keep again just keep moving it
down like this. It doesn't happen very
often, but it would when it does.
It can be very exciting.
Um
I'm just trying to
you know, my my heart rate is getting
excited now because this is exciting,
you know.
Um
we're pretty much at the area of of
I've never had a trade over 5K
um win at this size, so this is
exciting, but also trying to just say,
"Okay, you know, I'm I'm just trying to
stick with my strategy here
of previous trailing stop candlestick.
This is getting big now,
but I've learned over time is just keep
the stop there, and I'll try and let it
have a 50% pullback.
But again, this is spiking to the
downside, so again,
it does have that big chance to whip
back, so
I want to see this candlestick whip back
a little bit. That's okay if it punches
a new low, and then I'll, you know, move
my stop down again.
I'm pretty much just moving my limit
order down.
Uh I'm not going to really let it get
filled. Sometimes I just won't even have
the limit order.
Um but it's just on my chart now, so I'm
just going to leave it.
Nasdaq has actually hit the low So,
we're we've broken the lows here on a
ES.
And then the Nasdaq has just hit the
lows. It hasn't broken the lows yet.
So, that's what I'm watching there.
Just kind of waiting for this to do its
move. Again, it might have a watching it
do a 50% pullback from the lows. Maybe
it comes up to this low and bounces.
I'm trying not to think the fact that
I'm up 6K on the trade.
I've locked in
over 5K, so
biggest trade ever so far, so that's
really exciting.
And this is where, you know, it it might
have a pullback here and it might get
out. And that's totally fine. You know,
I want to hold through it doing
this, but if it as soon as it starts to
show some strength, it can do this.
That's how these moves work.
And so, you know, I'm letting it do its
pullback here. It looks like it's going
to knock me out like 5,100 or something.
Yep, we're out. Sick trade. So, that's
it for the day. Now, if you want to
watch this live in the mornings, I have
started to live stream on YouTube for
free. I'll start my live stream about 15
minutes before the stock market opens
Eastern Standard Time, and then I will
do this exact same thing every single
day, and so you can come watch me there
and trade alongside me. Now, if you want
to learn more about the strategy and a
clean polished tutorial of how I
identify these setups step-by-step,
check out this video right here.